why don't we speak next to
jill from burbank jill welcome
jill welcome to the program
hey
uh can you hear me david yes
okay perfect
uh i have a basically one question how
can we take seriously a party which is
the republican party yeah uh that is pro
coup
pro
you know traders pro
anti-democrat you know anti-democrats
democracy
uh how can regular people take him
seriously and consider them as a
party like a major party well because we
have a very sick country i mean you're
you're pointing out something uh jill
which is
v it's astute in its simplicity
in much of the world your average person
looks at the democratic party looks and
then and then looks at the republican
party and says wait a second so the
democrats are i mean like i'll give you
my opinion the democrats are not nearly
left enough but here's a list of 15
things they want to do that seem
reasonable and they generally support
democracy and
whatever and then you look at the
republican party and it's trump's
winning primaries they're doing
everything from openly supporting
stealing an election that they didn't
win
all the way to you know
more minor but insane stuff like just
making fun of disabled reporters all of
it and in many countries people would
say there's really only one option there
you've got to vote for the democratic
party that republican stuff is crazy but
we have a very sick country here and we
have a lot of people who don't see it
that way and they seem to love the
republican party they seem to see it as
a as a legitimate participant in the
political system and so as i've said
many times before
crazy candidates and wild parties exist
in many parts of the world
but without millions of people to vote
for them they don't really go anywhere
and the us is so lucky that we have not
only the candidates but the people to
vote for them as well
but but i understand the crazy people
yeah we're we're actually not gonna
consider the crazy people because you
know they always exist yeah this is
about regular people
uh my question is specifically you know
uh
about them
how can the regular people of the united
states i know there is third thirty
percent of the united states that is
crazy
uh but the rest are not
regular you know joe schmoe going to
work every day
not following any politics yeah but when
it comes to you know
every four years okay you know they get
a they get a mail-in ballot and they
fill it out
they do a little you know research
and find out hey i mean they also saw
what happened on on january 6th yeah how
can you be back and be like okay no you
know what i'm going to go pau you know
republican party
that just does not make any sense to me
at all i'm i'm with you and i think that
so first of all remember
close to half the country doesn't vote
so first of all
half the country isn't even voting so we
can kind of eliminate them
of the half to 55 percent that does vote
half of them vote for democrats instead
of republicans okay so now we're down to
like 25 of the country of the 25 of the
country that votes for republicans
you've got basically three groups
the people that are just
ignorant to the facts and so we include
we can include in this both people who
don't know anything and also supposedly
like the crazy people the people that
just have no idea what's going on that's
one group then you have the bad people
okay these are people who they they see
what's going on and they want it they
want to discriminate they want to
separate children from family you know
all these different things and then
you've got the third group which is
people who they understand what's going
on and they have some selfish reason for
voting for trump anyway like they saw
that he was crazy but they thought he
would lower their taxes so so these are
like the three groups
so it's if you imagine that those groups
exist sort of evenly each group of those
is like eight percent of the country
that's a lot of people because the u.s
has such a large population but it's
actually not a huge percentage of the
country
jill
all right
i guess jill's gone
let's go next to laura from summerville
laura welcome to the show
laura hello hello
hi how are you
i'm doing well how are you
pretty well so i have a question
about the midterms please how much of an
impact do you think that aipac is going
to have when it comes to
the midterms and maybe you've already
covered this elsewhere
uh i don't know i mean i've not covered
it is
are they try are they having a
particular impact i've heard nothing
about aipac for years
laura
sorry
yeah can you hear me yeah
okay
so in terms of funding
towards campaigns that are
more pro-palestinian
are there particular campaigns that
you're i don't know if i'm losing half
of what you're saying laura or if this
is the whole question i just is there a
particular race you're talking about i
mean it's there's so many different pacs
and interest groups and they're all
funding candidates and opposing can i
just don't know if there was like a
specific race or something in particular
that you had on your mind
i think overall
across the country i've been hearing
that just from other sources i didn't
know if you
if you had an opinion on that no not i
just haven't heard that this particular
year that there's anything in particular
happening who are you hearing that from
laura
all right
thank you laura i don't know what was
going on there but very very strange
technical elements there surprising
my audience knows i read i read a ton of
books i read nonfiction i read fiction
at night i'm always trying to consume
information and the truth is i don't
have the time to read every non-fiction
book that i would like to read one thing
i do not have time to add to what i'm
reading in paper form
is more history but i want to know about
history and that's where our sponsor
blinkist comes in blinkist doesn't
replace reading books cover to cover the
way i love to do but for example with
everything going on right now with roe v
wade i wanted more of a detailed history
of roe v wade in the united states so on
blinkist i was able to get a 15-minute
condensed audiobook of the mary ziegler
book abortion and the law in america roe
v wade to the present and in 15 minutes
i get a great overview blinkist also has
slide presentations that will take you
about 15 minutes to go through so
it's not to replace reading it's in
addition to for me you get the key
takeaways from blinkist from the books i
would certainly otherwise miss out on
you can try blinkist for free for seven
days and get a 25 percent discount off
of a subscription
at blinkist.com pacman the link is down
below